the symbol for this video is this which
represents the abstract dimension so
what I'm going to be talking about are
the dimensions of physical quantity and
why they're used
Life magazine published photographs of
this first explosion big magazine at the
time with a wonderful spread and the
photograph showed the blasts from the
bomb increasing with time the photo
showed the radius of the cloud and there
was a scale on there in 100 meters so
from that photograph you could estimate
the diameter of the blast
maybe they didn't realize that they were
giving away useful information because
it seemed as though nobody could work
out how big the bomb was from what was
seen but physicists knew lots of cunning
techniques to do this and one of them di
Taylor was able to estimate that it was
a 1020 kiloton bomb that is equivalent
to not one t one kilogram of TNT but
twenty thousand tons of TNT so this is a
really big bomb and it's quite an
accurate estimate it turned out of the
the power of the bomb so they let out
this military secret sufficient
information that somebody was clever
enough to work out how much the power of
the bomb was and he probably was
followed around by the CIA and mi5
thinking that he was a spy but he did it
using basic fazilet physical principles
so did he what did he do with his
findings and did he tell people no he
didn't he did nothing worse than that he
published in the Proceedings of the
Royal Society of London so it was out in
print and for everybody to see I guess
physicists are slightly unworldly in
some respects and didn't realize how
they could be persecuted for being so
slapdash with security a few months
later President Truman had to release
the information he was out by about 10%
which is in remarkable but then he was a
very very astute person working with
hydrodynamics how did he do it well he
he there is a basic idea when you're
doing measurements of every physical
quantity such as mass that you put it on
a scale such as this scale which shows
you the mass of few kilograms and you
pull it down and the spring brings it up
and from reading this you can get the
mass this is in kilograms or grams but
there is an abstract quantity which is
the mass
and if I put the brackets around this
this no longer is in units just is how
the physicists will think in an abstract
way about what masses and this takes it
away from any sense of units so it's not
in kilograms it's not in ounces it's not
in pounds or whatever you can do the
same thing with lengths you can have a
meter ruler this is a new plastic one
going from nought to 100 centimeters or
even have it foot ruler or whatever but
the concept of length can be represented
with a little bracket round it has
length now time is more difficult but I
imagine in roman times they had candles
like this with little lines on it so I
can have another concept which is time
and I'll put that in brackets so this is
the abstract quantity of time not in
seconds years month days this is a
thermometer not an ordinary thermometer
that your mother would shove in your
armpit or elsewhere this is one that
goes from a hundred degrees centigrade
down to naught degrees centigrade and
now I'm at a loss because I've used T
for temperature time so I'm going to use
theta for temperature there's one last
one which is shown over here it's an
electrical current as I move the current
up I can get it to swing round to
whatever values because there's a moving
coil in there that measures the current
so these are the five basic units and
that's going to be current some people
use charge but I prefer current in units
this would be a meter this would be a
second this would be a Kelvin this will
be a kilogram and that would be an
ampere those are the five basic units
but forget about units is nothing to do
with units
Tylar invented a law of physics based on
the density of the air the radius and
the time and the energy of the bomb an
equation involving those four parameters
and he put it together in such a way
that this law was just a pure number
independent of any of these units and as
a result of that he could write out an
equation for the energy with an unknown
constant but he knew what that constant
was because he knew with ordinary bombs
tiny little bombs that were in shells
and dropped from planes what the blast
radius would be so he knew what that
number was and then he scaled it up to a
larger scale and then estimated
precisely what the tonnage was the way
of combining these together is called
dimensional analysis and it's a
particular technique mathematical
technique which gives you the first rush
at any law physics that you unearthing I
think he showed that military
intelligence was a bit of an oxymoron